emile durkheim is one of the three big
names in modern social theory next to
Karl Marx and Max Weber
Durkheim's called the father of
sociology the formal study of society so
he focused on social rather than
individual explanations for things when
looking at racism for example he
wouldn't look at individual psychology
and circumstances he'd look at stuff
like economic inequality or media or
migration Durkheim had a name for this
social stuff
he called them social facts so norms
culture values law morality population
size political institutions technology
they're all social facts social facts
affect one another and they affect
people but while social facts have their
roots in individuals they can't be
understood at the level of the
individual law and morality aren't
things that exist inside the heads of
individuals they exist in the network of
interactions between people like how
consciousness exists not in any one
neuron nor pineal gland but in the
networks that they form point being
Durkheim was into social explanations so
I've got a basic idea of what to
accounts about let's look at one of
these big ideas so solidarity is the
cohesion in society what holds it
together
it's the feeling the individual members
have that they were part of the whole
Durkheim proposed two different ways
that solidarity can work mechanical
solidarity for pre-modern societies and
organic solidarity for modern societies
what's pre-modern mechanical society
like well let's say you're a bloke
called Sven you'd be white and bearded
and you'd believe in Thor and you'd farm
potatoes for a living and everyone
around you would also be bearded white
people also called Sven who also
believed in Thor and also farm potatoes
and since you and everyone else you
interact with does basically the same
stuff as you they have the same
experiences as you hold the same values
of course realistically there will
probably be some differences and
divisions men and women might have
different social roles there might be a
leader of some kind with greater
responsibilities and privileges but the
point is that for the most part people
in their societies are bound together by
commonalities similitudes and likenesses
what Durkheim calls collective
consciousness religion is a big part of
this but all the little shared
experiences matter - it all contributes
to the basis of pre-modern mechanical
solidarity similarity now modern society
is obviously very different there are
lots of different people with different
gods different jobs different
experiences different values there isn't
a lot of similarity here so what holds
society together the answer according to
Durkheim is interdependence what this
means is that while all these people are
very different they rely on each other
unlike Sven here who is pretty much self
sufficient as long as he's content with
potatoes the modern person relies on the
butcher and the policeman and the banker
and the teacher in the bus driver and
the child laborers who make our clothes
and the person who makes the intertubes
work we need each other and that's what
holds modern society together the
analogy here is that organic society is
like a human body with individual organs
each doing their own specialized job to
keep the whole system working there's
still some collective consciousness here
some similarity but it's limited to some
very general and indeterminate ways of
thought and sentiment which leaves a
room open for a growing variety of
individual differences
those are Durkheim's words and they're a
pretty good reflection of modern society
right we all have pretty different
experiences and values but there are
some basics that we all share in how we
live and think and feel one thing in
particular that's valued by most modern
Western societies is individualism
emphasis on the value and interests of
the individual rather than wider society
individualism is particularly visible in
the culture of consumerism the endless
acquisition of things in order to
gratify the self that is economically
and socially foundational in the modern
world I mean just turn on a TV we are
constantly told that we are free unique
individuals living and thinking and
buying in whatever ways satisfies or
expresses asked personally so
individualism is one of the few things
collectively valued by modern society
Durkheim likens up to a religion but he
also points out that even though
individualism is collectively valued it
doesn't promote social solidarity
because it's not to society that it
attaches us it is to ourselves so one of
the few things that just about everyone
does have in common in Western modern
society ironically does not unite us we
are very much separate individuals bound
together
largely by our reliance on one another
so one of the key differences between
mechanical and organic solidarity is
division of labor
in a pre-modern society everyone does
basically the same stuff especially if
you take it back to hunter-gatherer
societies but in modern societies
everyone has these highly specialized
roles specialization is powerful
individual people can make specific
individual bids which come together to
make something that no one person could
have made alone but a consequence of
individuals only knowing how to make
their own specialized bit is that they
can't survive alone so again organic
solidarity is based on specialization
which creates interdependence which is
the basis of social cohesion in one
societies one other difference is
related to law so in a mechanical
society everyone tends to have the same
values so when someone breaks the rules
people respond emotionally and intensely
so you get these harsh biblical and
medieval punishments in organic
societies on the other hand everyone
believes different things there isn't
this great unified morality so you
usually don't get this huge collective
mob outrage thing so much but since
everyone depends on everyone else to
follow the rules the focus of law is on
righting wrongs making sure that the
system keeps working so instead of
getting creative with our punishments we
focus on correcting and reforming people
who break the rules at least in theory
in durkheim's words the judge speaks of
law and says nothing of punishment this
is called restitutive law distinct from
retributive law interestingly Durkheim
saw crime as a natural and healthy
feature of society it sort of reaffirms
and makes clear society's laws to have
transgressions occur and be dealt with
which you know is an old argument is
there no way to reaffirm society's laws
without breaking them and disrupting
society it's hard to see chronic violent
crime as a healthy part of society but
anyway Durkheim also discussed what
causes the transition from pre-modern
mechanical solidarity to modern organic
solidarity
he said it's caused by dynamic density
his term for the number of people in a
society and the degree of interactivity
between them we see this in contemporary
globalization people goods money and
information are all moving across the
globe faster and further and easier than
ever before dynamic density is
increasing and has been for some time so
Durkheim argues that as dynamic density
increases competition increases creating
a natural dry
for society to find more efficient ways
of doing things so system like the
division of labor arise and gradually
become a foundation of organic
solidarity according to Durkheim organic
solidarity interdependence comes from
greater density and interactivity so now
a really quick criticism Karl Marx
founded a line of thought called
conflict theory he wrote in his
communist manifesto that the history of
all hitherto existing society is the
history of class struggles Freeman and
slave patrician and plebeian blah blah
blah oppressor and oppressed Marxist
thought sees capitalism and therefore
modern society as being founded on
domination exploitation and alienation
now Durkheim does say that there can be
problems with the division of labor one
is what he calls the enforced division
of labor he says sometimes if changes
too fast or society otherwise messes up
you might get a situation where economic
power or status is determining who
performs what economic role rather than
actual qualifications another kind of
problem he calls the anomic division of
labor
basically there's too much individualism
and people are cut adrift in their
highly specialized activities left
without a clear idea of what is and is
not moral behavior in this state of
anomie people are isolated reduced to
the repetition of meaningless tasks
Durkheim recognizes both of these things
as bad but save them is unusual and
temporary phenomena that society quickly
corrects with new rules and systems
basically Durkheim doesn't think
economic baptism class conflict are a
big deal to the extent that he
recognizes class conflict as a thing he
argues that it's not the cause but
merely a symptom of social problems so
easy right
it does seem pretty clear that there are
severe and unjust imbalances of power in
the world that arise from the division
of labor look at world wealth inequality
at how much tax big companies pay at
what goes on in the special economic
zones where all our phones are made look
at revolutions slavery social equality
movements class conflict and the
enforced and anomic division of labour
are not only more than brief and rare
aberrations but pretty foundational
parts of how the world works Durkheim
just didn't sufficiently recognize
conflicts generally it's been pointed
out that Durkheim one of the most
significant social theorists
I could offer little sociological
explanation or consolation on the first
world war probably the biggest world
event of his time Durkheim's whole
social thought is so focused on
solidarity that it fails to see conflict
and conflict clearly is a profound
influence on society throughout history
so Durkheim's contrast between
mechanical and organic solidarity is a
pretty interesting way of looking in
society and contemporary phenomena like
consumerism and globalization illustrate
that it's a pretty accurate conception
of the modern world but it fails to
capture the flaws in the division of
labor described by marx and conflicts
generally which are major forces shaping
the modern world
thanks for watching this video let me
know if you'd like to see more of this
kind of content
you